foreign
magic mushrooms also start signaling to
hone in on the other parts of the body
that have been experiencing a lack of
love and to give them a stretch
a massage more dedication
massaging the core parts of the body
that are used so much
but gets so little
massaging relaxation attention
intentions
follow the rocket to the source of
Infinite Creation become the source of
Infinite Creation Within
unleash the kingdom of emptiness
comprehending Infinite Creation
complete openness to new discoveries
words
don't do it justice it's ineffable
the pointing
with you
reuniting with
all
[Music]
the Indescribable mystery the source of
Infinite Creation
brand new place to stretch massage that
I've never
really hit before Oh
oh my gosh that's so good oh
unbelievable new massage discoveries
you tuck your finger in right there
where the leg meets the Torso
tuck your finger
and then put varying
pressure
in several different locations
wear legs and torso meet is a critical
place for massage
maximizing longevity
preventing pathology
think about it mainstream society when
was the last time that you even passed a
couple minutes just relaxed
and digging into the tight parts of your
body that are desperately asking for
your attention
I Am Not a Human
I am only the source of Infinite
Creation
visualizations of fractals
infinite tree leaves
as much as God or the absolute is a
a loving
blossoming energy
there's also a
energy
5 15.
45 minutes in
the only symbol
that can do describing
foreign
Justice
is
the question mark
see the question mark
is
unbounded
it is freedom
that's why
the greatest
have been unable
to describe it
evades language
just is
and this is why
so many
as we secrete Wonder
what's this about
woke me up from my
slumber
in nothingness
for what
a question mark
this is why many of the
traditions
I've talked about it as Leela
as the play
the divine
clay
about an hour in
I am being brought into the heat of the
question mark
my
thirst
for metaphysical truth
being answered
by a question mark
unbounded
freedom
unbounded freedom
like if you took the intestinal tract in
all of the villain that absorb nutrients
we've flipped it
inside out
and then that
endlessly
secreted
explored
infinite possibility
you'll never come to the end so just
enjoy
laughs
a PhD in metaphysics
it's expressive essence
being both of that in nature peace and
happiness yet also not
bounding it at all
with those
as descriptors
to love the Sun
and to be grateful for the son
and to know
the great utility of all 8 billion
humans having
direct access to the Sun
abundant beaches abundant trees abundant
parks
crazy though even
absolute this endless mystery wants
to experience
the lowest lows imaginable
along with the highest highs
the same
planet
the most horrendous Warfare
mixed with the most luxurious imaginable
just is
this reminds me of the fishes
asking
where's the ocean
you're in it
the question mark
has no need
to fulfill
yet is the ceaseless exploration of
possibility
do whatever you want but
don't hurt anyone
do whatever you want but maximize human
potential
just be just be it that's it just be it
have fun
play
dance sing
just be it
and recognize that you are the question
mark if you have a weapon
you're just pointing it at the same
question mark
and so there you go
your morality is right there
why would the same source
ever
damage
the same source
out of exploration
unbounded mystery
and to have 100 percent radical
acceptance
for the atrocities
emerging
of this question mark
100 percent
radical acceptance for the
question mark
metaphysical mystery
for its atrocities and for its
beauties
are one
and speaks so
profoundly to as you emerge
love yourself accept yourself become the
question mark
become the one infinite
creator
as you emerge
love accept yourself
come the one infinite creator
question mark
but Divine Transcendent no blame
or you can go and hang out in the park
the question mark doesn't give a [__]
as beautiful as your North Star calling
is
the same time you can go and lay in a
park or on the beach
play some basketball
smoke
wear a suit
handle the planets
economical matters
literally
question mark
and that's why these
Mystic Traditions are just like
here now
just be here
now just
that
nowhere to get to
nobody to become
already the question mark
ceaselessly exploring
question mark talking about itself
versus just relaxing
as a sunflower have a North star
there's a sequoia tree have a North star
does a dolphin have a North star does an
ant have a North star
it's both equally cool to completely
vaporize yourself as it is to go and lay
in a park
or achieve a Transcendent Noble aim
equal to just
steal yourself
into the Timeless essence
of just being aware the one infinite
creator
as equally as
go and occupy yourself with things to do
far as you can imagine
simultaneously
absolute still
one infinite with
in
still
one infinite question mark
out
whatever you want
far as you can imagine
enjoy
this is the closest
I can get
to show you what's happening
the camera
turned on itself
no seriously this is what I'm doing I'm
literally talking to
an object
on a tripod in the corner of the room
about my
five grams of
magic mushrooms while I'm just laying
on the corner of my bed in the sunlight
so that
it can also beautifully be understood
the expressed
the question mark
has radical acceptance
for the
cages that are in the schema the
framework
yet
it wants to break out of that
because there's so much to explore
there's so much to understand
and when you're just trapped in a
Ima asiamo
you are choosing arrogantly to
heighten the question mark
firehousing
both the fact that we radically accept
you for exactly as
you are as the creation is
yet also recognize that you've created a
prison
for yourself
you've created a prison for yourself in
your own mind
self-realization literature is about
going Inward and recognizing the freedom
that you are
and you've arrogantly chosen to create a
prison
your mind
you've
quelled
the
fire-hosing question mark
playfully melting cages
radical acceptance for
emergences of the question mark to
choose to
throttle arrogantly
the
creative capacity
but do they know
do they know
what exists
a bit
dissolving of that fake ass boundary
that they've set up
so it's almost like
in a sense
kind of midwifing
the
mystery
to
The Matrix
midwifing what is most free
to what has arrogantly
choked and put itself into a prison
I am so free that I can make
a prison
for myself
I'm so free
exploring doing whatever that I will
artificially make a prison for myself
and then I'll write a whole [__]
narrative about
exploding out of that prison
the love story of the individual
as well as the love story of the
collective
the question mark
does not compute your qualification
this is just Freedom that's all it is
it's just an expression of freedom
that's it
all
of the concepts
and the Frameworks and the schemas and
the prisons
just obliterating
those
the artificial prisonification
blasting through the artificial boundary
the question mark created for itself to
play
an artificial boundary
and what am I to do
the answer is a question mark
the answer is freedom
beautiful
zero step
room stuff
you already
freedom
as we write this whole extravagant story
for ourselves
a beak
in a box
I will not to be in a box the question
marks like I will not be in a box
so fun
because it's unbounded
unbounded freedom
and so when it's put into the bounded
constraints
to take you out of the prison
that you've artificially created for
yourself
famous first line
the Dao that can be named is not the
Eternal down
it's just
whatever the question mark
is writing in this case the one infinite
Creator writing this insane
Odyssey
for itself
you are the freedom that writes this
Odyssey for itself
who are the freedom that writes this
insane Odyssey for itself
that's the joke is that you think that
you took up all of the space with a
universe
but the joke is is that the whole thing
happened in a dimensionless singularity
you think it took a universe to write
the story
but it all happened in a dimensionless
singularity
that's how free you are
[Music]
again you're so free that you have to
create
the illusion of
a prison
like a planet in this inhospitable
vacuum
that
secretes all of these individually
humans
where
they
organize themselves into governments and
economies and
the left and the right
taking on their own name
you can only refer to me
this individuated expression as
four letters
John
okay
you're gonna inhibit your freedom
right off the bat
and say you can only refer to me as John
everything's about a limitation of
Freedom everything
freedom you're right
the
limitating word
upon such a massive
plot of land
so you can have this massive plot of
land called the United States
of America
and you're going to call it something
and you're going to have this massive
plot of land
insane in this Odyssey of the universe
called China
or Russia or the whole continent of
Africa and then you're gonna take the
individuated
secretions of that
planet
and limit their movement between these
massive plots of land
with passports
this is hilarious you could not write
something funnier
than Freedom limiting itself
Freedom limiting itself
wow
unbounded freedom
writing stories about limiting itself
unbounded Freedom writing stories about
limiting itself
you're so free already
you're gonna write
a story
about limiting yourself
in the form of a universe
and the whole thing
takes place in a dimensionless
singularity
it doesn't even take
the space
of a universe
because
just like this
is just like this
foreign
you are so free
in such a question mark mystery
that you created a universe that is
seemingly so large
just for you to be the witness of said
extravagant
Odyssey
through a pupil
through these
the pupil itself
is where the
absolute is
the pupil is where freedom is
we wrote the whole universe
into this story
of your pupil
that's how free you are
it's been fascinating seeing what the
magic mushrooms are sharing with us
today
on this psychonautic Adventure
again the magic mushrooms are telling
you you are so unboundedly free
that you wrote the whole universe into
your pupil you're so unboundedly free
that you wrote the ex extravagant
Odyssey
but the universe
watch the whole thing take place in the
dimensionless singularity of
consciousness
and now we'll come to where the
legs meet the Torso for a massage
so funny
that
it's right there
I am the absolute
using a universe
writing such a grand
narrative about myself
and then locating myself
in the pupil
as the Sioux Legend goes
no surprise that this secreted from that
area
hide it inside
it's the last place we'll look
hide it inside it's the last place we'll
look
that's it
whole thing can be written
and boil down to that hide it inside is
the last place we'll look
you're so free and So Divine
that you create
the
extravagant
experience
of a universe and the whole thing
happens in
you're so free that you create the
illusion of
having your freedom be bounded
you're so free
you create the illusion
that your freedom can be bounded
Jesus this is crazy
the whole thing boils out of the freedom
the absolute
boils down to Freedom
there you go
and you've created
the illusion
of putting yourself into bounded
boxes as humans but you're the absolute
freedom that is both nothingness of a
pupil while it's the everythingness
of a universe cool
you're so free it just boils down to
Freedom
and you can write the absolute
and this is simply what it's like
to spend
eons
bounded
ineffable release
that is felt
upon the liberation
so free
that I'm going to keep myself
under the illusion that I've been
locked up
I'll write a whole
Odyssey about it
so Indescribable or free
lunch